foreign
what's up Randall
in 2019 I went into credit card debt and
you know 2020 hit went out of work for a
while let all my credit cards lapse on
me now I'm being sued by my credit card
company and I need you guys wisdom on
what to do hmm how much do you owe man
um
all together about 17
000 for this particular credit card six
thousand
are the other ones going to be suing you
in short order are you still are you
current with them
uh the other two are in collections this
one is the actual credit card company
decided to sue me okay
um
how much how much money do you have yeah
yeah I can get a hold of about two
thousand dollars that's the max I have
right now okay dude the way you said
they're gonna murder somebody how are
you gonna get two thousand dollars
the way you just said that like I said I
can get a hold of it
my family understands that I just
started the baby steps and they're
willing to help me cover this if I can
get them to settle it's the most they'll
be able to help me with though
because my sister just had a big
Financial issue herself so okay my
mother wanted to help us both out of it
okay
um right now how much money do you make
a year
I make a little over 13 an hour
what do you do can I work full-time
I'm a gas station attendant I'm also
going to college okay okay what are you
studying
uh accounting ironically enough
accounting huh
all right
um how are you paying for school Randall
I took out student loans at the start
but when I first found out about Dave
Ramsey I stopped taking out student
loans and I've been
barely scraping together enough each
semester to be able to cover my pocket
okay okay have you paid where are you at
for this semester have you already paid
for the full total or are you paying and
increments for this I have three
payments total I've paid two of them for
the semester I have one in November one
in November okay
um
um okay I don't I here's my here's my
knee-jerk reaction Randall
um the money from your mom is this just
a gift that she has Surplus and she just
says I want to be able to help you or
you expected to pay this thousand
dollars back to her
I would have to pay it back yeah I know
it would be a family loan yeah
um she needs help out at property so she
wants me to work it off instead of
actually paying her sure sure okay
here's the deal Randall it's six
thousand dollars which I know is a lot
okay that's a lot
but it's not 60
000 so you have a thousand dollars to
your name you could get another thousand
from your mom as a loan uh you're going
to school you have there's a lot of
stuff Happening Here
and you get paid 13 an hour where you're
at which is drastically under what you
could there's a lot of places that are
20 25 an hour so here's what I would do
if I were you Randall because I how old
are you
foreign
ran into near homelessness right after
high school yeah
so it took me a long time to get back on
track to where most people start at
right after high school sure
absolutely yeah you've had a hard Road
this is a lot
but I I have confidence in you Randall
and I have confidence in the numbers
that I'm seeing so I would keep your
thousand dollars as an emergency fund
and then I would go
and I would Uber drive for Uber I would
work night shifts somewhere I mean I
would go crazy work like you've never
worked before with a minimum of saying
20 an hour or whatever it is because you
there's a lot of places that are that
are hiring for much higher than what
you're doing and I just think if you get
your income up over a period of time
you're going to be able to pay this off
and I would call the credit card company
and say hey I got you know I got 500
bucks to my name and you're not going to
get anything so so either we we settle
this and we get on a payment plan and
you get that in writing to be able to
knock out a bunch of this really quickly
uh with a lot of work and and that
that's that's the road I want to take
because I think Randall for you
there's going to be something in this
process for you
that's going to give a sense of dignity
and I think that you know going into
debt with your mom all of these things
they sound good in the short term but I
think you have the ability to fix this
Randall I really do
Randall here's a question I want to ask
you brother
are you tired
oh very much
like this has to be old like your
sister's gone through this you've gone
through this you're almost homeless you
and I could probably talk for a couple
hours over some nachos you had a rough
go of it as a middle school high
schooler is that fair
yeah yeah you're 26 you're 27. are you
just tired
yes very tired okay
here's the thing
Rachel just laid it out beautifully for
you
this isn't the moment to go cut corners
and to put your mother and your
relationship at risk by making it a
financial transaction now don't do that
stand up tall call that number back that
where they're suing you and you can say
I'm coming back from homelessness
I'm working at a gas station I'm in
school like Rachel said you can sue me I
got nothing for you
um you can put me on a payment plan at
this at this percentage rate and send me
a thing in writing and I'll settle for a
thousand dollars or two thousand dollars
that's what I can do and no the other
ones are coming too right
and then for the next 24 months man I
want you to work like you've never
worked before
can you do that
yeah we'll let me say this I know you
can will you
yes I plan on getting out of all these
deaths this is something that
has waited very heavily up in the last
few years excellent there's nobody in
your corner more than Rachel and I and
Randall we see so often I can't tell you
how many stories of this moment in
people's lives and we kind of call it
the sick and tired moment and this is
yours where you're like I'm getting sued
by this credit card company I have these
lingering things I feel like I just
can't get ahead it's just this it's one
after the next of not feeling like what
am I doing I've had it what I've been
what I have done up until this point is
not working I have to change and this is
your moment Randall this is it so hold
on the line Austin's gonna pick up uh
we're gonna send you both a copy of
Total Money Makeover Dave's book starts
the baby steps and your subscription to
finding uh to Financial Peace University
and I want you to have every dollar the
budgeting app so those three things
together own your past change your
future we're giving you a ton of stuff
Randall because we've been leaving you
you can do this this is your moment
Randall this is your moment to say no
more no more you've got this